stops on a dime back pedals over the  three-point line  push back up and in by deandre ayton  18 points for ayton five rebounds for  bridges  nine rebounds for ayton they are leading  a phoenix team in the second of a back  to back a huge two game oh my goodness  what a play by kawhi  whoa oh that happened so fast kevin  what he just exploded and got that up  there  there goes winner here's a whistle but  kevin look where he took  out from i mean look how quick this dunk  is  i mean the extension  right over ayton i mean this is your  seven footer  oh that's beautiful beautiful  yes that's exactly that's what we were  doing here  well i'd give anything to be there in  person uh sometimes you just don't feel  it when you're stuck in your basement or  watching this game with the delays that  we have and  boy even just watching it like all the  fans  that was spectacular leonard with 15.